هذه هي الصحفيه والناشطه الايرانيه
الامريكيه مسيحه لنجاد تستنجد من اضطهاد
النظام الايراني
والان وزاره العدل الامريكيه تكشف اسماءها
وصور المتهمين المعتقلين المعنيين بخطفها
العام الماضي وهم رافات اميروف وبولاد
عماروف وخالد مهديه العدل الامريكيه تقول
ان الاشخاص الثلاثاء تم توجيههم من قبل
النظام الايراني
استهدف في السابق ضحايا اخرين في كندا
وبريطانيا بدا الافراد الثلاثه بمراقبه
على نجاد في يوليو الماضي بشكل متكرر
بالصور والفيديو وخططها اميروف وامروف
لتزويد مهدي اف بمبلغ ثلاثين الف دولار
لشراء بندقيه وذخائر وفي الثامنه والعشرين
من يوليو في العام الماضي لاحظت على نجاد
نشاطا مشكورا خارج منزلها الواقعي بمنهات
في نيويورك وغادرت وبعد ان ابتعد مهدي عن
منزل الضحيه تم ايقافه لمخالفه مروريه
واعتقل حين تم العثور على سلاحه و 2,100
دولار وقنا عند تزلج اسود اما اميروف
فاعتقل خارج الولايات المتحده واقتدى الى
مكان احتجاز الامريكي بينما القي القبض
على عمره في التشيك في وقت سابقا من يناير
وتسع الولايات المتحده لتسلمه المؤامره
المحبطه من قبل تخطيط اجهزه المخابرات
الايرانيه كانت عباره عن خطف الفريق لمسيح
علي نجاد ونقلها الى ايران عبر زورق سريع
لفنزويلا منذ يونيو الماضي على الاقل وفق
الوزاره كان فريق المخابرات الايراني
يقدمه وثائقي مزوره ولكذبه بشان هدفه كما
استخدم الفريق محققين خاصين لمراقبه
الضحيه في عده حالات في عام 2020 و 2021
وفي تغريده لها اعلنت مسيحه لنجاد ان
مكتبه تحقيقات الفيدراليه ابلغها باعتقالي
من وظفتهم ايران لقتلها وعلقت بان الحرس
الثوري الايراني يقوم بهذه العمليات منذ
اربعه عقود رشه خياط العربيه